AT THE WHITE HOUSE WHERE THEY
WILL BE ANOTHER CORONAVIRUS
BRIEFING AT 4:30 THIS AFTERNOON.
JOINING US NOW, THE TREASURY
SECRETARY STEVEN MNUCHIN.
WELCOME BACK TO FOX NEWS SUNDAY,
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
YOU’RE EXPECTED TO BE UP THERE
AGAIN TODAY, WE HEAR THIS
PACKAGE IS NOW $1.8 TRILLION AND
MAY GO ABOVE IT.
IS THIS GOING TO GET DONE AND IF
SO, WHEN WILL THEY GET DONE?
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
AND I DO THINK IT WILL GET DONE.
WE’VE BEEN WORKING AROUND THE
CLOCK WITH REPUBLICANS AND THE
DEMOCRATS.
I’VE BEEN SPEAKING TO
MITCH McCONNELL, CHUCK SCHUMER
CHUCK SCHUMER, WE HAVE A
FUNDAMENTAL UNDERSTANDING AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WRAPPING IT UP
TODAY.
LET ME JUST WALK YOU THROUGH THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE PACKAGE
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT IS VERY
DETERMINED TO PROTECT AMERICAN
WORKERS, A MAJOR PART OF OUR
ECONOMY TO SHUT DOWN ON THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO PROTECT THEM.
SO THE FIRST PARTS ARE WHAT I
CALL SMALL BUSINESS RETENTION
LOANS TO IT IF YOU ARE A SMALL
BUSINESS, YOU WILL GET TWO WEEKS
OF CASH FLOW TO PAY YOUR
WORKERS, YOU NEED TO RETAIN
THEM.
YOU WILL ALSO GET SOME OVERHEAD
AND IF YOU DO THAT, THOSE LOANS
WILL BE FORGIVEN, THAT’S HALF OF
OUR WORKFORCE, THAT WILL ALLOW
SMALL BUSINESSES TO KEEP PEOPLE
AND MAKE SURE WHEN WE OPEN THE
ECONOMY, THEY ARE UP AND
RUNNING.
THE SECOND PART IS DIRECT
DEPOSITS, THE AVERAGE DIRECT
DEPOSIT OR CHECK FOR A FAMILY OF
FOUR WILL BE APPROXIMATELY
$3,000, YOU CAN THINK OF THIS AS
A BRIDGE TO GET THROUGH THIS
QUICKLY.
THE THIRD COMPONENT IS ENHANCED
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE LAID OFF DURING
THE CORONAVIRUS ON THE FOURTH
COMPONENT IS A SIGNIFICANT
PACKAGE WORKING WITH THE
FEDERAL RESERVE, UP TO
$4 TRILLION OF LIQUIDITY THAT WE
CAN USE TO SUPPORT THE ECONOMY.
WE CAN LEVERAGE OUR EQUITY
WORKING WITH THE
FEDERAL RESERVE.
ON TOP OF THAT, THE PRESIDENT IS
DETERMINED HOSPITALS NEED MONEY,
A VERY SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONEY FOR HOSPITALS AND MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS.
>> John: FOR THE HOSPITALS,
$110 BILLION, IS THAT WHAT
YOU’RE LOOKING AT STILL?
>> APPROXIMATELY, WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THE HOSPITALS HAVE
MONEY, THE BEST WAY TO GET
THROUGH THIS IS FOR US TO WIN
THIS WAR WITH THIS VIRUS.
>> John: LIQUIDITY IS KEY HERE
AND WHAT WE’VE HEARD SO FAR WITH
THIS BILL AND MAY BE EXCHANGED
IN THE LAST 24 HOURS WAS THAT
LIQUIDITY ASSISTANCE REALLY WAS
SECTORAL.
GOING TO THE AIRLINES AND CRUISE
INDUSTRY, NOW THE AUTO INDUSTRY
HAS GOT ITS HAND OUT AS WELL.
THERE NEEDS TO BE BROAD-BASED
ACROSS THE ENTIRE ECONOMY.
WHERE ARE YOU ON THAT FRONT?
>> WHEN THEY STARTED, THIS WAS
UNIQUE TO THE AIRLINES INDUSTRY
SINCE WE HAD SHUT DOWN MOST OF
AIRLINE TRAVEL BUT NOW WE SHUT
DOWN MAJOR PARTS OF THE ECONOMY,
BUT IT’S A BROAD-BASED LIQUIDITY
FACILITY WORKING WITH THE FED.
SO THERE IS A SMALL COMPONENT
FOR AIRLINES, NATIONAL SECURITY
COMPANIES BUT THERE’S A VERY
BROAD-BASED, WE CAN LEVER UP TO
$4 TRILLION TO HELP EVERYTHING
FROM SMALL BUSINESSES TO BIG
BUSINESSES GET THROUGH THE NEXT
90 TO 120 DAYS AS WE WIN THIS
WAR.
>> John: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
THIS DIRECT DEPOSIT.
IN $3,000 FOR A FAMILY OF FOUR,
ABOUT $1,000 PER ADULT, THAT WAS
ONE OF THE FORMULAS THAT WAS
FLOATING AROUND LAST WEEK.
SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS OF
VERMONT ALSO CONTINUES TO BE A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE SAYING
THAT’S NOWHERE NEAR ENOUGH.
LISTEN TO HOW HE PUT IT.
>> WHAT IN GOD’S NAME DOES A
$600 CHECK OR $200,000 CHECK
NEED ONE TIME WHEN YOU WERE
UNEMPLOYED?
YES, IT MAY GET YOU THROUGH
THREE WEEKS AND STRETCH IT AND
YOU THROUGH A MONTH BUT THAT IS
NOWHERE NEAR WHERE THE WORKING
PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY NEED.
>> John: YOU HAVE SUGGESTED IN
THE PAST AND OTHER WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS HAVE AS WELL THIS IDEA
OF A DIRECT PAYMENT MAY COME
INTO DIFFERENT TRANCHES.
ONE ON APRIL THE SIXTH AND
ANOTHER ONE ON MAY 18TH, ARE YOU
STILL LOOKING AT THAT OR IS THIS
A ONE-TIME ONLY THING?
>> FOR NOW AND THIS LEGISLATION,
IT IS ONE PAYMENT BUT LET ME SAY
THESE THREE PIECES ALL TIED
TOGETHER.
WORKERS WILL GET MONEY THROUGH
THE SMALL BUSINESS PROGRAM
THROUGH RETENTION, THEY WILL GET
MONEY THROUGH UNEMPLOYMENT AND
THEY WILL GET EFFECTIVELY THIS
BRIDGE CHECK PAYMENT WHICH IS A
DIRECT DEPOSIT SO THESE THREE
PROGRAMS ALL LOOK VERY QUICKLY
AND IF, FOR WHATEVER REASON, TEN
WEEKS FROM NOW THIS VIRUS, WE
WILL GO BACK TO CONGRESS AGAIN
BUT I THINK WE ARE INJECTING A
LOT OF LIQUIDITY INTO THE SYSTEM
AND HARDWORKING AMERICANS KNOW
THAT THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO
PROTECT THEM AND WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING TO SUPPORT THEM.
>> John: I WAS GOING TO ASK
YOU THAT QUESTION, WHAT IS THE
TIME FRAME IN WHICH THE STIMULUS
PACKAGE IS DESIGNED TO WORK?
SIX WEEKS, EIGHT WEEKS?
YOU MENTION JUST A SECOND AGO
TEN WEEKS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I HOPE THIS
GETS PASSED ON MONDAY BECAUSE WE
NEED THE MONEY NOW.
I WOULD SAY WE ARE LOOKING AT
THIS FROM ANYWHERE TO ATTEND A
12 WEEK SCENARIO.
BUT AGAIN, THE SITUATION IS
MOVING QUICKLY.
WE NEED TO GET THE MONEY INTO
THE ECONOMY NOW.
IT WE DO THAT, WE THINK WE CAN
STABILIZE THE ECONOMY AND PUT
MONEY INTO THE HOSPITALS IN THE
PRESIDENT HAS EVERY EXPECTATION
THIS IS GOING TO LOOK A LOT
BETTER.
>> John: IF THIS DOES GO
BEYOND TEN WEEKS, WE’VE SEEN
WHAT THE INFECTION CURVE IS LIKE
IN SOUTH KOREA AND CHINA, WE
DON’T KNOW WHAT IT’S LIKE HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES
PARTICULARLY IN NEW YORK CITY.
IT’S AFTER TEN WEEKS BUSINESSES
STILL HAVE TO REMAIN CLOSED AND
NO ONE IS FLYING ON THE
AIRLINES, CAN YOU KEEP GOING
BACK TO THE WELL?
WITH INTEREST RATES THE WAY THEY
ARE, BORROWING IS BASICALLY A
BOTTOMLESS PIT BUT HOW MUCH DEBT
CAN YOU TAKE ON TO ADDRESS THIS?
>> THE GOOD NEWS IS THE U.S.
ECONOMY IS STRONG OR DO WE HAVE
STOPPED MAJOR PARTS OF THIS BUT
WHEN WE GET THROUGH THIS VIRUS
AS I SAID, YOU’RE GOING TO SEE
THE U.S. ECONOMY COME BACK TO
THE STRIKE, WE HAVE GREAT
COMPANIES, GREAT WORKERS AND
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS HAVE A
BRIDGE TO GET THROUGH THIS AND
THIS ISN’T THE FINANCIAL CRISIS
THAT’S GOING TO GO ON FOR YEARS.
SO I’VE BEEN LISTENING TO THE
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS.
I THINK THERE’S A LOT OF
ADVANCES BEING MADE, DIFFERENT
TYPES OF TREATMENTS.
WE ARE GOING TO DO WHATEVER WE
NEED TO DO TO WIN THIS WAR AND
THIS BILL GIVES US A LOT OF
MONEY TO CREATE A LOT OF
LIQUIDITY IN THE SYSTEM AND
PROTECT AMERICANS.
>> 50% OF THE ECONOMY IS SMALL
BUSINESSES, PROVIDING LIQUIDITY
FOR THOSE SMALL BUSINESSES, THEY
HAVE ZERO REVENUES TO GET THEIR
MONEY TO PAY THEIR WORKERS, TO
PAY THEIR RENT, TO PAY THEIR
ELECTRICITY.
>> John: IS NOT GOING TO COVER
EVERYBODY?
>> THAT WILL COVER ROUGHLY HALF
OF THE PRIVATE WORKFORCE AND IN
MOST CASES, IT IS COMPANIES 500
OR LESS BUT THAT’S GOING TO
COVER ROUGHLY HALF THE WORKFORCE
AND AS I SAID, FOR BIGGER
COMPANIES, WE HAVE LIQUIDITY
FACILITIES, JUST FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WORKERS ARE PAID.
>> John: ARE WE CURRENTLY IN A
RECESSION?
>> I DON’T THINK IT’S TERRIBLY
RELEVANT.
ARE WE GOING TO HAVE REDUCED
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY THIS QUARTER?
ABSOLUTELY.
WHEN PEOPLE FOCUS ON RECESSIONS,
IT’S BECAUSE OF PROLONGED
ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT.
THIS IS A VERY UNIQUE SITUATION
WE’VE NEVER HAD BEFORE.
THIS IS THE GOVERNMENT HAS
SELF-IMPOSED SHUTTING DOWN LARGE
PARTS OF THE ECONOMY AND AS SOON
AS WE CAN GET THE MEDICAL
SITUATION UNDER CONTROL, WE ARE
GOING TO REOPEN IT TO THE EXTENT
WE HAVE KEPT ALL THESE SMALL
BUSINESSES IN BUSINESS, WE HAVE
KEPT WORKERS WITH THEM.
WHEN WE REOPEN THE ECONOMY, THE
ECONOMY IS GOING TO BOUNCE BACK
SIGNIFICANTLY.
>> John: "THE WASHINGTON POST"
REPORTED YESTERDAY THAT THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY WAS GIVEN
TO THE WHITE HOUSE WARNINGS BACK
IN JANUARY AND EARLY FEBRUARY
THAT THE COMING OUT OF CHINA WAS
VERY SERIOUS AND WOULD LIKELY
END UP IN A PANDEMIC.
WERE YOU OVER AT THE TREASURY
DEPARTMENT EVER WARNED THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS WAS COMING
DOWN THE PIKE?
THE INITIAL WHITE HOUSE REACTION
APPEARED TO BE DON’T WORRY, IT’S
OVER THERE IN CHINA, WHY DO WE
NEED TO RESPOND ROBUSTLY?
ONLY 16 CASES HERE.
WERE YOU EVER WARNED EARLY ON BY
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE THAT
THIS WAS COMING?
>> I WANT TO BE CAREFUL TALKING
ABOUT SPECIFIC INTELLIGENCE FOR
LET ME BE CLEAR AND THIS IS NOT
JUST IN THE U.S., THIS IS AROUND
THE WORLD, NO ONE EXPECTED THIS
TO TAKE OFF AT THE RATE IT DID.
AND EVEN AS YOU KNOW, I’VE NOW
BEEN ON THE TASK FORCE LISTENING
TO THE MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS FOR
A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
IN I SAID A FEW WEEKS AGO I FELT
COMFORTABLE TRAVELING ON
COMMERCIAL AIR FARE.
I DID.
THE SITUATION HAS CHANGED VERY
QUICKLY AND THE PRESIDENT HAS
RESPONDED TO THAT.
AS WE SAW THE SPREAD HERE, WE
HAVE SHUT DOWN AIRLINE TRAVEL
ABROAD WITH EUROPE, THAT WAS A
VERY IMPORTANT MOVE AND AS WE’VE
SEEN STATES, WORKING WITH THE
STATES IN RECOMMENDING THIS.
I DON’T THINK ANYONE SHOULD
SECOND-GUESS THE GOVERNMENT
ACTIONS, MOVING VERY QUICKLY AND
WE RESPONDED APPROPRIATELY.
>> John: THE PRESIDENT
BASICALLY ACTIVATED IT BUT
HASN’T YET PUT IT INTO PRACTICE
BUT WE HAVE STATES LIKE MICHIGAN
AND SO MANY OTHERS, GOING TO
TALK COMING UP A LITTLE BIT
LATER WHO ARE IN DESPERATE NEED
OF MEDICAL SUPPLIES.
GENERAL MOTORS IS VOLUNTEERING
TO MAKE THAT BUT DOES THE
PRESIDENT NEED TO PULL THE
TRIGGER ON THE DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT AND SAY GET OUT
THERE AND MAKE THIS EQUIPMENT
BECAUSE WE ARE RUNNING BEHIND,
THIS IS ONLY GOING TO GET WORSE
BEFORE IT GETS BETTER AND WE
NEED YOU TO STEP UP TO THE PLATE
NOW?
>> I KNOW THE TASK FORCE IS VERY
FOCUSED ON SUPPLY CHAINS, QUITE
FRANKLY I AM FULL-TIME FOCUSED
RIGHT NOW ON THE ECONOMIC SIDE
OF THIS.
WE HAVE OTHER PEOPLE WORKING ON
THE SUPPLY CHAINS BUT I HAVE
EVERY CONFIDENCE THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS THESE POWERS, HE
IS WORKING WITH PRIVATE INDUSTRY
AND WE ARE EXPEDITING THIS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
>> John: WHEN DO YOU EXPECT TO
VOTE ON THIS FISCAL STIMULUS
PACKAGE?
>> MONDAY MORNING.
>> John: AS ALWAYS THANKS FOR
YOUR TIME AND SEE WHAT THE